[Music]
hi guys it's quinn here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the youtube algorithm
really notices me
the novel do androids dream of electric
sheep by philip k dick
tells the story of a society so
devoid of genuine human connection that
its citizens plug into empathy boxes
just for a chance to feel a connection
with humanity of a world so decimated by
nuclear war that most animals have gone
extinct of a world in which we've
created an entire class of disposable
people and forced them into servitude
do android's dream of electric sheep is
obviously one of philip k dick's classic
books but it often gets overshadowed by
its adaptation but the interesting fact
is this book thematically
says something fundamentally different
from the blade runner movie
essentially the movie is saying
something to the effect of the androids
are really just like us
the book however is much more nuanced
the concept of empathy is brought up
over and over in this book
what is empathy is empathy necessary is
empathy even real we learn early on that
the main difference between androids and
humans is that humans can feel empathy
while androids supposedly cannot
curiously we carry this fact in our head
while also seeing the humans in the
story also not behave with very much
empathy and there are certain humans in
fact like phil resch who behave far more
soullessly than the androids and yet we
are still shown again and again cases of
androids clearly not possessing empathy
like for instance the spider dissecting
scene
like i said most animals have gone
extinct in this world so living
creatures are very rare you have the
character izador who finds a spider and
he shows it to the androids who he's
helping out and then he's horrified when
the android pris dissects the spider
right in front of him the android
doesn't necessarily behave maliciously
it simply just does not feel empathy for
this living creature and is fine with
cutting off its legs one by one to see
if it can still walk
so a big theme in this book revolves
around examining the artificial
mechanisms by which we engage with our
own emotions and our own humanity so i
mentioned the empathy box but they also
have devices which allow them to dial in
specific moods so rather than letting
emotions come and go naturally emotions
are now delegated to a machine
just as empathy is now delegated to a
machine
another aspect to this is there is want
and desire in their society but there is
no fulfillment having a living animal in
the society is seen as a great status
symbol so everyone wants a living animal
but they're very very expensive so most
people settle with electric animals so
that's where the title comes from do
androids dream of electric sheep and
there's more to that title that we'll
talk about in just a second the main
character deckard is a bounty hunter and
bounty hunters hunt down androids who
have escaped their masters on mars and
come to earth to hide and he's doing the
specific job that he's on in this book
hunting down the nexus six models
because he wants to buy a living goat
for his wife so all genuine human
emotion is delegated to a machine
and everyone is obsessed with acquiring
what are essentially meaningless
objects and even empathy is produced to
something that is ultimately false
something that is ultimately artificial
and in the real world humans don't seem
to engage very empathetically with each
other
so if you've noticed the similarities
between what i've described in this book
and the modern world
then you're not alone in noticing that i
can't help but think of the internet
when i think of the empathy box and the
idea of this artificial way of engaging
with empathy like you'll see a
children's hospital burned down one like
equals one prayer i got all these people
liking it and something about that
artificial expression of empathy
engages a similar area in their brain so
they don't feel the need to be
empathetic
in their real life because i'd like this
post online it's a very weird phenomenon
but something that definitely happens
so i don't think philip k dick is
necessarily saying
androids are just like us he's saying
that there is something about humans
that is different the fact that we have
the capacity for empathy but he's also
giving us a warning that basically says
we shouldn't become
like them that on this evolutionary
journey that we're on we should not lose
our empathy for each other and for life
in general so let's break down the title
of this book do androids dream
of electric sheep so as i mentioned the
only thing people really want in this
society is to acquire these electric
animals so the question in the title is
essentially asking
what do androids want
what do they desire
are they the same
as our desires
for humans empathy is a choice
you can choose to be a monster like phil
resh or you can choose to be a better
person now this book is full of really
interesting concepts and i want to dive
more into some of them in other videos
but right now i really want to get to
something that i found extremely
interesting this book brings into
question
what even
is real what does artificial mean does
it matter if anything is artificial this
is such an interesting book and a little
bit of a confusing book because you end
up questioning every aspect of it to the
point where by the end i don't even
think it's clear whether or not deckard
himself is human or android
yes it is pretty much established that
androids can't feel
empathy
but empathy
can be
a choice and it is implied that the
androids might be able to fill empathy
for
similar androids to themselves
so if that's possible then maybe empathy
in general is possible but i think
what's important is it's making us
ponder the question does it really
matter and i think that's the point
maybe it matters maybe it doesn't but
that's up to us as
society to figure that out for ourselves
so at the end of the book you have
deckard encountering a frog out in the
desert he brings it home he gives it to
his wife and then she tells him that
it's electric
and also a kind of creepy addition to
this is that we have no idea how that
frog got into the desert an electric
frog just doesn't appear in the desert
someone had to put it there that aside
at the end of the book although the frog
is electric deckard's wife begins to
care for it she orders a terrarium for
it and fake flies for it so ultimately
it doesn't matter whether the frog
is electric
or living
so in future videos we'll talk about the
empathy boxes and the religion of
mercerism that is surrounding them we'll
also dive more into the concept of a
disposable race of people and compare
and trust how it's handled in this book
to other science fiction stories because
a lot of other stories have also done
this concept so this novel is actually
quite short but it's also very dense and
it's written in a way that might confuse
certain people so if you're not used to
reading philip k dick you might be
thrown off slightly by the writing style
but just know you don't have to
understand it the first time you read it
the book is meant to make you ponder for
a long time on certain concepts and even
hardcore philip k dick fans will admit
that philip k dick does at times kind of
have a strange writing style that
doesn't make it any less enjoyable for
me but i'm also a weirdo so thank you
guys so much for watching make sure you
like and subscribe for more quinn's
ideas tell me what science fiction books
you'd like to see me cover next on this
youtube channel
just a heads up for those of you that
may be interested my next graphic novel
the lie behind the star is launching
february 2023 you can sign up now to get
on the email mailing list to get
notified as soon as it launches more
information on my website link in the
description thank you guys so much
[Music]
you